170 millionen teilchen weltraumschrott
eine riesige gefahr
wir haben ja schon öfter darüber
berichtet unzählige herumfliegende teile
die eine gigantische zerstörungskraft
haben und jetzt gibt es eine neue
beobachtungstechnik aus deutschland was
destra kann und wie uns dieses radar vor
verheerenden kollisionen schützen soll
jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
die aktuelle bedrohungslage ist groß 60
jahre raumfahrt haben ihre spuren
hinterlassen
trümmerteile ausgebrannte raketenstufe
oder defekte satelliten das sind die
teile beispielsweise es gibt schätzungen
nach denen mehr als 20.000 objekte mit
einem durchmesser von mindestens zehn
zentimetern um unseren planeten kreisen
und zwar unkontrolliert und rund 750.000
kleinere müll teilchen die etwa ein
zentimeter groß sind und von der erde
aus nicht zu erkennen sind die kommen
dazu
mit jedem fitzelchen sind es sogar rund
170 millionen teilchen eine riesige
belohnung für die etwa 1500 aktive
satelliten die wir derzeit im weltraum
haben
doch nicht nur die riesige menge an
weltraumschrott 2700 tonnen andere
schätzungen sprechen sogar von 6500
tonnen sondern vor allem die hohe
geschwindigkeit der teilchen die ist
extrem gefährlich schneller als eine
gewehrkugel rasen sie durchs all
selbst die kleinsten müll kollisionen
können verheerende folgen mit sich
bringen treffen sie beispielsweise auf
satelliten module kommt es zur korrosion
die vorzeitige alterung der getroffenen
module ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten doch
das ist noch nicht einmal der worst case
denn selbst schrott teilchen von einem
zentimeter größe können satelliten auf
einen schlag komplett zerstören das hat
direkte folgen für unser leben auf der
erde
denn nicht zuletzt brauchen wir
funktionierende satelliten um zu
telefonieren wetter vorherzusagen oder
uns mit dem navi von a nach b zu bewegen
und im weltraum gibt es eben nun mal
keine straßenverkehrsordnung oder
polizei dafür aber jede menge
geisterfahrer das einzige also was
bleibt ist den weltraumschrott ganz
genau zu beobachten
dafür gibt es radar die schrott teilchen
werden damit vor einer möglichen
kollision aus gemessen so dass ein
gefährdeter satellit beispielsweise
rechtzeitig umgelenkt werden kann aber
nicht alle müll teilchen können damit
identifiziert und beobachtet werden
sie sind eine riesige gefahr und können
dass kessler syndrom auslösen dass
unsere zivilisation um jahrzehnte
zurückwerfen würde
das kessel syndrom startet durch einen
crash innerhalb von stunden werden ein
großteil der satelliten rund um die erde
zerstört inklusive der internationalen
raumstation iss immer wieder schlittern
wir an dieser katastrophe vorbei es gab
bereits 200 kollisionen im arbeit der
erde und jede produziert
wieder neue schrott teilchen inzwischen
geht man von etwa 170 millionen trümmer
teilchen aus die um die erde stören
wir sind quasi im moment zeuge eines
kessler syndroms in zeitlupe
spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009 stoßen der
iridium 33 das iridium satellitentelefon
netzes gewicht eine halbe tonne und der
russische satellit cosmos 2251 zusammen
bei einer aufprallgeschwindigkeit von
rund 40000 kilometern pro stunde bleiben
von beiden satelliten nichts mehr übrig
außer rund 100.000 schrott teilchen sie
haben jetzt die chance für den nächsten
unfall deutlich erhöht um sie zu
beobachten gibt es rava stationen auf
der erde und die usa sind damit etwa 30
stationen ganz weit vorne
und von denen sind wir hier in
deutschland auch abhängig der großteil
der satelliten und trümmerteile des
weltraums sind in einem öffentlichen
fest katalog festgehalten doch es gibt
auch welche die geheim sind deutschland
hat jetzt nachgezogen um diese unter
anderem zu finden denn auch wir sollten
in der lage sein den schrott im weltraum
zu überwachen und zu beobachten
dazu haben das deutsche zentrum für luft
und raumfahrt und die luft verfallen
experimentelles überwachungs radar
konstruiert sein name gäste
das steht für german experimente
surveillance and tracking jordan mit ihm
sollen die bahnen von satelliten und
trümmerteilen in 500 bis 1200 kilometern
höhe erfasst werden es besteht aus einem
empfänger und einem sender der gepulste
signale in dem weltraum schickt in vier
kilometern höhe verdichten sich diese
signale zu einem netz und das macht es
möglich die müll stücke die hindurch
fliegen zu identifizieren die empfänger
auf der erde analysiert die daten und so
kann die flugbahn der müll teilchen
vorhergesagt werden und satelliten
können dann einer kollision ausweichen
auch bei geheimen teilchen geßler passt
in einen 16 kubikmeter großen container
das heißt dass ranner ist auch mobil
einsetzbar 2018 soll der testbetrieb
anlaufen zudem soll gestern demnächst
mit dem weltraum rada tyra vom deutschen
fraunhofer institut in wachtberg
kooperieren nicht nur die beteiligten
forschungsteam setzen viel hoffnung in
gestratz gerald braun vom deutschen
zentrum für luft und raumfahrt in bonn
sagt zum einen fangen wir an einen
deutschen bahn laden
von weltraum trümmern aufzubauen den
brauchen wir zivil und militärisch sagt
braun
denn bislang müsse auf amerikanische
daten zurückgegriffen werden zum anderen
sei gestern auch ein prototyp um gezielt
die forschung für künftige weltraum
beobachtungen zu fördern
wenn ihr kein video zum thema
weltraumschrott und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann tut
mir ja kein abo aufs auge und vergesse
nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
weltraumschrott das ende der raumfahrt
droht mit noch mehr infos zum drohnen
kessler syndrom
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran